Aaron frisbee
Chandler rules Joey Harbor Greg get in
the house get the house
how we doing today I'm doing we got a
call down there at the department some
aircraft taking off from our Reno
airport's been receiving some fire some
bullet rounds
what airline was it doesn't really
matter
Frisby honestly I don't shoot it airline
alien aircraft you only shoot at alien
aircraft what I think is there alien
aircraft et stuff uh-huh how would you
distinguish that from regular aircraft
it's got aliens in it what if you start
with alien spirits aircraft
what if alien they were just you know
doing a little uh drop mind you start
taking shots at them and suddenly holy
we just took a first shot at alien
spacecraft
it's good question what's your name
Travis Travis Travis that's a good
question
thank you how lucky look I like you're
lost out thanks a lot but a nice house
got a good good wife second cousin doing
man hi I'm good thanks if we were to
look say for example in that bunker that
covered with the tarp right before we
came over I ain't been over there and so
long I have knotty I haven't been over
there and you never make it through this
corner of the yard
well we keep ours this is not yours oh
honey that shut up I'm sorry
Brisby yeah I got this at a yard sale
what so you shouldn't have these kids
right there that and the oranges all
right so just Parker huh get to it all
right put the hand in here we go he's
beaten bleedin bleep
that was pretty cool can I do it next
circle half
you